i want to be really careful with this
next topic because i bring this up to
you not because i think it's something
to laugh at but it's something to take
seriously
um and to think about in terms of
solving the serious problems that face
the country and that face humanity today
we we now have a sort of combination of
different studies which tell us
something that many of us suspected
intuitively and it's that on average
trump supporters aren't that smart and i
know that this is going to seem
pejorative and that it is going to make
many people extraordinarily defensive
and maybe it's even going to make people
mad at me
but i think that it's not something to
laugh at it's just a phenomenon you know
if the right wants to insist that
intelligence differences exist and of
course intelligence differences do exist
it's just the right likes to insist on
them along certain lines then they would
have to be open to the idea that
intelligence differences can exist among
political stripes
and we're going to look at some of that
data right now and then sort of talk
about the implications our our friend
chauncey de vega
has an interesting article a commentary
in salon called new research on trump
voters they're not the sharpest tools in
the box trump's voters lack cognitive
sophistication often believe that the
bible is the literal word of god and in
this article and i encourage you to read
the entire thing chauncey writes as the
new faith in america survey by deseret
news and marist college highlights the
basic
understanding of the role of religion in
a secular democracy has become so
polarized that 70 percent of republicans
believe that religion should influence a
person's political values whereas only
28 percent of democrats and 45 percent
of independents share that view okay so
that's a difference on sort of
separation of church and state fair
but uh the study goes on to point out
republicans and democrats liberals and
conservatives also don't consume the
same sources of information about news
and politics conservatives now inhabit
their own self-created media echo
chamber which functions as a type of
lie-filled and toxic closed episteme and
sealed off universe the creation of such
an alternate reality is an important
attribute of fascism fascism and it then
goes on to cite research by darren
sherket a professor of sociology at
southern illinois university which
demonstrates that america's democracy
crisis may be even more intractable than
the above evidence suggests in his
article cognitive sophistication
religion and the trump vote
shuriket examined data from 2018 and
concluded there are substantial negative
differences between the thinking
processes and cognition cognition of
white trump voters as shown in the 2016
presidential election compared to voters
who supported hillary or another
candidate
circuit observed that trump's support
has been linked to religion and level of
education but until now not to quote
cognitive sophistication which was found
to have a positive effect on voting
but a negative effect on choosing trump
what that means is
cognitive sophistication is defined in
this study
higher cognitive sophistication makes
you more likely to vote
but less likely to vote for trump
and the article very interestingly
explains
low levels of cognitive sophistication
may lead people to embrace
simple cognitive shortcuts like
stereotypes and prejudices
amplified by the trump campaign
additionally the simple linguistic style
presented by trump may have appealed to
voters with limited education and
cognitive sophistication of course of
course we suspected that
beginning with adorno's classic study of
the authoritarian personality empirical
works have linked low levels of
cognitive sophistication with right wing
orientations
last paragraph and then we'll discuss
trump's campaign may also have been more
attractive to people with low cognitive
sophistication and a preference for low
effort information processing because
compared to other candidates trump's
speeches were given at a much lower
reading level
while much of trump campaigns rhetoric
and orientation may have resonated with
the poorly educated and cognitively
unsophisticated these overlapping groups
are less likely to register to vote or
to turn out
in an election you can read this study
the study is called cognitive
sophistication religion and the trump
vote it's free to read
uh on the wily online library
and i would encourage you to look at
that so
i mean listen
it's really tough to have this
conversation because anytime you're
saying a particular group isn't as smart
it is seen as pejorative and
understandably so and it is seen as
offensive in some way and so on and so
forth we had this instinct intuitively
that there's no doubt about that and and
very early on there was data pointing in
this direction
we now have
some
what i would call evidence or proof
which is on average trump voters are
less cognitively sophisticated they are
more likely to believe untruths look at
the study they are more likely to be
literal believers of some elements from
the bible
i don't see that and laugh like that's
not funny to me i want to solve problems
and one of the things that i've said
many times is when we have to argue
about
this is a shorthand
dumb things
we aren't
arguing about or debating or working
towards solving real and complicated
issues
when we have
57 percent of the republican party
believing that the election was
literally stolen from trump by biden and
that trump's the rightful winner
and we have to you know fend off more
than 60 frivolous lawsuits in court
making that case and all of this
different stuff when we're fighting that
we're not actually fixing other problems
like hey we've got a disastrous
gerrymandering problem in this country
as one example when it comes to voting
when we are arguing about
is there any
of what we are experiencing in terms of
climate change that we can link to the
activities of industrialization and
fossil fuel emissions when we're arguing
about that and some percentage of the
the american public doesn't believe that
we aren't taking steps to actually uh
get off of fossil fuels
and live more sustainably because we're
just trying to argue about the the basis
of fact so i don't see this and laugh
and i know that it's very easy to just
say oh stupid trump supporters
it's really a much more complicated
issue and it also relates to education
it relates to culture there are
geographical realities here there's
issue about access to
um education and health care and so many
different things so we should take it
seriously we shouldn't laugh and again
much like the anti-vaxxers for example
they are a danger i mean without a doubt
they are they are a serious danger
and they also are victims of
disinformation to a degree and as
frustrating as we all realize it is to
have to argue with people about
no
the vaccine doesn't magnetize you
and no mrna vaccines weren't rushed it's
based on a platform that allows their
development to be faster
as much as we have to argue it's
frustrating to have to explain this
stuff
they are also victims and unless we fix
the mechanism that victimize them to
fall for this stuff just going to keep
happening again and again
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blink is for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below